[Music]
greetings
and i'm pleased to say that i'm
really delighted to be here um and to
have an opportunity to talk to you
about what i call neural philosophy
and that is a subject matter that is
kind of at the interface between
the philosophical questions about the
nature of the mind and
how we think and decide how it is that
we're conscious
and on the other hand developments in
neuroscience
one of the most remarkable things i
think in neuroscience
in the last 25 years or so have been the
technological developments
that have allowed us to investigate the
brain
in much finer and much more profound
ways than where possible uh ever before
and i'm going to start actually by
talking about consciousness partly
because
that is an area that has been considered
so mysterious that no one could ever
make any progress on it
and yet and yet we see progress
in neuroscience of a very distinct and
very important kind
now with regard to the question about
the nature of consciousness
roughly speaking there are two
approaches
one is to develop a great grand exotic
theory about the nature
of the phenomenon itself
and it is typically kind of very rich in
metaphor
but very data poor the other
approach and and this is one that i
favor
is to try to make progress on a very
specific
question about some aspect
of the nature of conscious experience
now we might want to begin with a
definition of consciousness but
as with any phenomenon whose science is
not yet
really well understood we can't give a
precise
explicit definition but what we can do
is make certain kinds of contrasts
between conscious states and other
states
and ask the question what's the
difference in the brain
and in particular what i'm going to look
at today
are two questions what is the difference
in the brain between
someone who is about to have an
epileptic seizure
and has dissociative phenomena meaning
they have experiences which they don't
consider to be theirs
and what's the difference in the brain
when we're under
general anesthesia and not and in both
cases
we've learned a lot now we have in
anesthesia a very practical problem
we want during surgical procedures
to reduce pain or abolish pain
if you're having knee surgery for
example
you do not want uh to experience the
pain
of having that surgery accomplished
so this is really not about zombies or
about what is conceivable by somebody
and some possible
fancy word fantasy world
this is about the kinds of procedures
that people like you and i
undergo about root canals appendectomies
kidney stones amputations gunshot
removal
it's about pain and the loss of
consciousness
interestingly by and large the great
grand
theories of the nature of consciousness
such as that
everything in the world including
protons cow pies and fungus
are conscious have essentially nothing
to say
about how we reduce pain during surgery
this is a slide just to remind you that
surgery
is not just a sort of sweet casual
affair
it does involve removal of structures
and is often extremely painful and even
something like a root canal
can be very very painful if you have no
anesthesia
now cocaine in the 1880s was the first
drug that was used in dental and eye
surgery
to reduce pain and by about 1905 it was
replaced by procaine or as you
might call it novocaine and
the novocaine since i'm sure we've all
been to the dentist is injected
right next to the tooth that is going to
be worked on
now how does propane work is it spooky
is it weird does it involve
uh prayer no what it does is
it operates on the neurons
the nerves themselves and it changes the
structure of the neuron
so that the neuron cannot spike and
hence cannot send a signal
to the brain and so amazingly you feel
numb and you do not feel pain that you
would otherwise feel
i want now to turn to general anesthesia
because that's a place where for many
years
people use particular um
general anesthesias such as ether which
was
the first use was in the 19th century
i mean just think about that before that
time people
had their legs removed they had tumors
removed
without it benefit of anesthesia they
were maybe given
whiskey but that didn't help very much
so what do we know about propofol
which is the the general anesthetic
which is most widely used
and we have two very important domains
of research
one is research on humans and the other
is on non-human primates
emery brown at mass general is
a a gen a an anesthesiologist
and he's been very concerned both for
practical and theoretical reasons
about how it is that propofol actually
does the job that it does and he has run
large-scale experiments on healthy
humans
who were volunteers to see
if you administer propofol very slowly
over time
and then reduce it and and
stop the profile very slowly over time
what precisely happens in the brain
using emery brown's results um
people in earl miller's lab realized
that what we had to do was not only put
electrodes on the scalp of humans
undergoing propofol anesthesia but we
wanted to put those electrodes
right into the brain itself to precisely
find out whether
specific cells are involved and if they
are
how they change and so this work is very
recent the work on non-human primates
basically the story is that it is
entirely consistent
with the research on humans so what does
it actually
do how does propofol render us
unconscious how is it that we feel
nothing hear nothing see nothing
when we are under the influence of
propofol
the fast answer is that there is a large
decrease
in the firing rate of neurons
in two structures the cortex
and in the thalamus now
it turns out that there's a more
fine-grained answer
but first of all you might say well how
does it
change the firing rate of
of neurons in these areas and the answer
is
that it interacts with an inhibitory
transmitter namely gaba
to increase the functionality of gaba
it enhances gaba
so let's go into a little more detail
about how propofol renders us
unconscious
the answer is kind of multifactorial
because it involves
large regions of the brain and
so it's not just in a tiny area
that there is a reduction of spiking
rate
but it looks like in the conscious state
you have a kind of
coordination of responses to input
from externally as well as internal
input
involving motivation and hunger and
thirst
you have large coordinated responses
over wide areas and that with propofol
it's as though the coordination
drops out of the picture that we see
uh small regions that are are
are coordinated within themselves but
there's a lack of coherence
across the brain now in this slide it's
a little bit
complicated but this is the slide
that is taken from the work on non-human
primates
and what you're seeing in slide a
are the results of the electrodes put
in four specific regions
of cortex and to see how
the firing rate changes
when propofol is introduced and it's
introduced at this
double line and these are the four
specific
regions prefrontal cortex area 8a which
is also
frontal posterior parietal cortex
which is more towards the back superior
temporal gyrus
which is sort of middle rear and
basically what you're looking at then
loc
means loss of consciousness and we see
that right here
and recovery of consciousness and the
dotted line
begins to mark that the way that that is
determined
is responsivity to a particular
sound stimulus we can go into that later
but what you're looking at then
is really quite remarkable and that is
that the firing rate uh before the
propofol
is introduced is at these levels
and notice that it's not exactly the
same in all of those regions
but as propofol has introduced the
firing rate drops
and when there is loss of consciousness
you see the firing rate
go way way down and in
b what we're looking at is roc recovery
of consciousness
so you see that the firing rates are
very low
propofol is turned off and recovery
begins
and firing rate increases
now this is really quite a stunning
discovery but it's not exactly
interpretable as though the brain itself
all shuts down
in actual fact what happens is to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas